you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens we are here on the game
spot co-op stage at e3 2016 rounding out
the show with a look back at the best
things we experience we saw we loved at
e3 2016 i am your host Chris waters
joining me on set I have joven Shire
what up man he wasn't expect me to go
all the way down the line I have that
individual attention I appreciate it i
give it to you and now i'm gonna give
this sohinki hey is a little better
that's good okay I'm Ali zircon what are
you going on everyone yeah okay last
year's e3 lot to talk about vr AR this
is a future this year's e3 it was still
office BR was still very much on
everyone's minds still a big part of
sony's presence it didn't feel like as
much of a huge push but we still had
some great experiences very intriguing
experiences revealed anyway as we talked
about III each year has as the theme
we've touched on that a little bit last
year I was Villar like everyone and they
are and they are with Microsoft like
everyone was announcing something and so
this year you got to see that's what we
were talking about well now this is what
we're doing and we some of the subscribe
I was surprised to see like resident
evil Absalom fully playable from
beginning to end on PlayStation VR I was
like oh it may that's what we can expect
yeah especially without hitting watching
the the demo it just makes sense hi it
looks like i will be throwing up
everywhere but from what year and your
ear and they are to be our song it's in
the factor it's really funny that she
that you mentioned that i think we've
come a long way with with the game
mechanics and how the games are being
built for VR from when we had like the
first dev kits of oculus where you'd
have like one or two-man teams creating
a game right versus now you have Capcom
what are getting their hands in the VR
and like it's the motion it's when you
have a controller in your hand this one
I've gotten it is
controller in your hands before BR it's
left stick moves your body right stick
moves your head and we became a custom
that you know when you now you give
yourself your eyes your eyes whip it but
you're moving your head to move your
eyes while you're sick moves your head
so it's finding the best ways to to
create movement and we're seeing
something like excellent fighter as soon
as they announced that I'm like yes
that's a dis rain a chase I can look
around in the cockpit I can fly my
x-wing this is what I watch cop games
are a perfect fit I mean II Valkyrie has
been great already and like it's yeah
you don't have to worry about that
motion thing we're like okay I'm legs
and i am the torso that moves like this
yeah that's not you that's not how you
were but that is how you work if you're
playing a first-person shooter on a
console and speaking of of movement I
think my biggest surprise was with the
announcement of Batman Arkham okay then
being able to to witness the demo it was
very interesting that they went with a
style that I thought was best used in we
played budget cut on the magic cuz I
could talk about oh yeah it's for like
20 minutes straight and high for those
who didn't play that on the vibe you
would uh shoot a portal out you can look
it is a stealth game so you can look
what's around the portal and then your
help will actually warp debtor owes a
teleport system you never had to worry
about moving against its life you can
move around in that little square yep
but essentially you're moving your
square around and because it's a stealth
game they give you the option to peek
around and stuff before you actually
decide to teleport to that location
which yeah and I'll wait to see more of
budget guy it was just a demo we've
gotten to play so far but yeah it's
great because you don't have to worry
about the motion sickness or anything
and it really gets you into the action
like when the robots are coming at you
you're like ducking behind stuff like
that you're not having to worry about
where the controller is moving because
it's just where you're moving that
matters interesting like VR extension I
think of the detective mode even like
yeah yeah which and I think all that it
almost feels like it was a perfect blend
but to have the teleport movement system
in the Arkham VR was like all right I'm
Batman I'm teleporting around I'm
teleporting around so that was um
the surprise for me but you really did
feel like Batman and that was what they
were trying to convey with EDD Batman
what was it that made you feel like
Batman so the first part of the demo is
all about suiting up you start as Bruce
Wayne you go to a fully functional up
piano you play notes play the right
notes door opens and you can go into the
Batcave and you have to put on the glove
put on the glove myself and a few others
I've talked to you about the same issue
where they go to put on the cowl it's
bunk oh yeah that's right I'm like
yourself in the face I'm playing a video
game I don't know God all times in other
games ah budget cuts we're up in a
ceiling and I'm trying to look down I
get up on the ground he said I look at
his head look through a hole and I'm
gonna hit the ground that's why I was
great the floor is not gonna give either
that's just go right straight girls I'm
gonna go through a few vibes um but I
love ya i'm waiting for is where they
get rid of the wire because we also got
tangled in the wire just left turning
around trying to see all the robots
hopefully i think they'll be the next
evolution of VR I saw the VR backpack
out on stage yes yeah the press
conferences yeah well which um bulking
what he was before he see gaming press
comrade it was it it was like lift it
looks like that I'd like some armored
backpack situation you definitely look
like a beetle person like from The
Hunger Games yeah but I hey the wires
that's where we go angled up great you
know I think it's your point about the
teleportation I feel like we're gonna
look back at that in three years and be
like remember when they hadn't figured
out moving in VR yeah yep that's why you
should think it's such a good boy hey
though like so budget cuts and now
Batman V R it really feels like this
these are the first games that are
beginning that process where it's like
this is what VR can be right now this is
what you can feel like you wouldn't
accidentally hit yourself in the face
because it feels so real hanging in
there and with the second half of that
batman demo was all about being in
detective mode how much took you back to
what it was like in Arkham Knight where
you can kind of like get a crime scene
fast forward time
and rewind time trying to figure out
what happened it's a demo so I don't
feel like this is much of a spoiler but
yeah spoilers for a demo VR experience I
come on yeah so but the person that's
dead that you're investigating that
crime scene I was shocked because like
this is official Arkham cannons I'm like
oh it's sad to see it but then you have
to like go through and it really got
dark you see them trying to escape and
like where their neck cracks and it's
like this batman game is dark i'm seeing
what it's like to be in that universe
would you like fast-forwarding time
rewinding time going around finding the
different clues that's the Apple hooking
up here to figure out what happened up
on this spot you feel like Batman I
heard you can also swing Batarang yeah
unlimited batarangs I'm limited
batarangs first drive yeah a little less
dark transitioning yeah voila Shrek yes
definitely less dark than Batman and and
I think like if you're not gonna move
around you might as well be in a
captain's chair yeah right I don't know
what to did put the shields into the
back and yeah what I found most
interesting about that was first of all
I love the presentation about having
like all the Star Trek cast members
using it together yeah that's great that
was um but what that really got me
thinking was how many of my friend like
we're in a unique situation we're
friends but we work on a YouTube channel
we're all together yeah we'll have a
couple playstation vr s but what up like
the normal consumer and his friends like
how many PS VRS will there be and having
a four-person co-op experience it might
be a little more of a stretch to achieve
but still great also you open yourself
up to trolls because i know if if i was
jumping in random games i saw there you
know i'd be like trying to figure out
how do i transport people off of the
ship and just like into space it is like
whoops oh yeah those look like they're
about to attack let me just lower all
the shield
no it'll be that guy but make a nice
flick see if thieves right we're yeah
yeah cp's that's another great well yeah
I think you know one of the time you
make a good point see people playing VR
together it raises the question how many
thousands of dollars had to go in right
putting the set up together however if
you're someone trying to sell VR you
don't you want to like have those
experiences where if you sell one person
the adopter then they're going to turn
into the proselytizer and be like yo get
this we could we can Star Trek bridge
command together broad sir i'll be your
Jordi is that you want you to be my
Picard it'll it almost brings back what
LAN parties used to be yeah you have to
bring your replay station with your
PlayStation VR delve into need my
friends yes and you get to do it again
and you know it's something that that
did stuff like that before like I would
love to do Star Trek PR at my friend's
house and like hey guys let's get
together yeah dibs on Picard because you
know on the captain yeah and then let's
play we were watching and we were like
we have to get George Takei don't play
this game with us I don't be silly mom
yeah do you think Ubisoft tried to try
to get him in there I I don't see he
hadn't been busy because he'd be such a
great go-to you know Ubisoft wanted it
and I feel like that game needs to have
a way for you to like shake your fist in
fury or like throw something at somebody
to like miffed them off the head in
frustration cuz they're not do you get
the picard facepalm as long as i get
that motion i'll be happy does everyone
is baseball is molding mode into the
what else do we have a raw data had a
new build here which is a another great
we played on the vibe tell me about raw
data it's not a title on familiar with
all right so in raw data i don't know if
it's been available on oculus I know mm
piping's that utilizes the two cameras
and it puts you into a space okay and
enemy robots can appear all the way
around you and you get to choose in the
first demo you had you can choose from a
sword and like hit back bullets is great
you can get double pistols so you get a
shotgun okay
you saw like other guns that you can
wind up using none of the first demo
those guns are now available and I've
never felt like more of a badass and
I've done some pretty badass things in
my life he hasn't yeah but like a
duration there was a moment where I
picked up one source like oh I have two
swords great and I'm like I'm like
slicing that uh robots in front of me
and then like I hear a shot come from
behind me and I just want and then like
hit from like block behind me and I look
over my shoulder and I just see the
bullet fly back in the person it's like
that's what you get with raw data I
don't do like these multiple levels it's
just made me realize that I have no idea
how to swing a sword robots near mean I
was just like no way put this on you
everyone good yeah everyone's yelling me
you need to swing it that's not how you
swing a sword I was like right if the
developers of raw data are watching I
had a moment in the game that I would
really like address is I too went double
swords and I was blocking and stuff and
then I had I had one robot who wasn't
shooting at me and I had robots over
here who's shooting at me I'm like I got
to get rid of this robot and I just I
just kind of reacted and I'm like sword
throw and like I like launcher wait
which doesn't that which doesn't throw
the sword yeah our second Vye give you
are if you are willing to sacrifice a
control like that I think it should
reward you with a sword through ugly
just cost you hit yourself a lot of
money I feel at least they could have
let me take out that robot yeah I feel
like the developers were mike classify
that as user error but why not reward
user anything scenario that just shows
what VR is like it's so in company
tricks your breath like you said when
you put the black you start doing things
that just like feel intuitive to do and
sometimes they work out and other times
not so much if you like almost every
time I go off the headset I'm like oh
the world yeah yeah it's funny can I
have a similar yes I have a similar
reaction but more like oh the world
yeah I'm back in here now well speaking
of exaggerated motions right I feel like
vr is turning us all into the gamer from
the 90s commercial right like we're all
kid right yep Oh all the extra giant
move and so I was doing that today I got
to play Farpoint sony's sort of new
announced a shooter on an alien planet
oh yeah to go with the like like rhombus
gun controller they have that's got a 22
it's like thumb sticks it looks like a
gun but definitely doesn't look like a
gun so everyone's safe it's like it's
like some dad kid is like give me a gun
toy get me a gun so he's like I get some
PVC piping and puts it together there
you go enough like it that the kid's
gonna be cool with it but not Christmas
in my house nothing weird yeah yeah the
only don't stare the BBC sci-fi rubber
bands make something cool it's a
creators kids so I've got this thing in
my hands and one of the one of the gun
you know what these startling us all
rifle and it's did not you don't have to
reload it just overheats if you fire too
much yeah what did i do when i notice
that the like end was getting real hot
in orange haha yeah we thought about
making that work cuz it could like that
microphone Annika yeah yeah we didn't
put it in not like a 14 foot in that
would be hella yeah but so naturally
doing this to be our ah but so I played
that one and it was the first time that
I like I mean you know you do this sort
of that you've done you've done shooting
stuff you don't blocking stuff and it it
feels good it feels cool i'm like
dodging I'm trying to do like action
hero stuff like getting it down in my
hip and firing and like moving around I
think that far point game the demo they
have here feels like a pretty like it
feels almost like an experience you know
in terms of like the scale of it right
it's kind of like this is maybe not what
I qualify as a full-fledged proper game
but I think VR it's good i think it's
sort of harkens back to that old in the
argument of like is it a full-fledged
game games could be any size can be any
limb can be anyway
so I had a good time with it and I shot
some bugs and felt a little cool i like
how it was cackling with delight at a
few times always a good sign well it's
what I see how to use that as a
transition you're right it's like you
seem like these smaller games or you go
into these larger scale which my biggest
shock with the above but that's the
announcement of fallout for next year on
the vibe yeah and immediately I'm like I
can't even fathom being in that world
and I'm very curious to know how
movement works i haven't played it yet
yeah I want to know is it a
teleportation because it is vibe and
there is a at least how I play there's a
huge step stealth element so I want to
have those moments where I'm behind
something that I see a Raider so I
popped around the corner get my shot and
take it and I just I can't wait to be in
these universes to be in that universe
and if they haven't said it yet but dear
God if they don't i'll be angry Skyrim
yeah I remember like I feel like this
you roar at people yeah yes um let's go
let's go even further let's get like I
any Bethesda we've the doom we are also
like what a great fit to be in that
world that's why I love er I'm entering
the movement thing I was going to say
has anyone seen that omnidirectional
treadmill I forget who makes it I feel
like there's a couple try an infinite
treadmill everyone look that is he is
that the solution the movement problem
cuz you would actually be moving bullet
I saw people demoing it but I couldn't
see this game and they didn't have one
of those those tracks to it no I i don't
know i don't know if it's a teleport
everyone Lord really goofy when they use
that thing you feel like awkwardly lean
forward your lean into it right but
let's keep it real ain't nobody looking
cool playing vo ha ha you look like a
dirt we actually put googly eyes on our
body we do that too yeah it's just you
got it lean into it just like naked
great minds are you like yeah also I
feel like you know to our point about
putting your face into the ground or
chucking the controller it should be
mandatory to like just set up a GoPro to
watch you while you play VR yeah at like
at least over six hours or something
until you work out all the kinks in you
remember you've got the head mounted
explain your not like literally what
like I was serving tennis balls and
whacking myself in the face so graceful
I've whacked other people in the face
yeah everyone's got a watching you
really grievously so that is my zone
yeah if you come in my zone you might
get smacked in the face if I do that you
don't stand on the tracks when the
train's coming I stupidly set up our
office where the play zone is like
between the door and our desk you have
to walk through this like zone of
ecology getting yet so you have to it's
almost ascetic minigame it's like get by
the guy with the VR controllers before
without getting destroyed now I have
that be our variance yeah speaking of
fallout 4 how about this VR experience
right and then using the control ah dude
we're always gonna be a riot on your
aura and you know which I thought was
not gonna be kind of slipping down or
your iPhone's not going to be responding
yeah like sure there it is alright turn
turn nah it's going to be it's so
perfect it's so perfect and so fallout 4
in dhoom two of the end resident evil 7
you know we're not sure exactly what the
scope of that game is but this is really
the first III where we're seeing triple
A's we're seeing these big franchises
attached to VR making V up making you
know either adapting to be our or just
moving entirely into the VR space the
goal is just like like who's who's gonna
be the first one who's the early adopter
that's gonna do it right first and I
think everyone wants to jump into the
space yeah even a even razor announced
that they have their TK 2 unit i think
is what it's called which it has like
full steam support it's just very
interesting you see all these major
players jumping in which is fantastic
for us because now the more competition
competition just it breeds excellence
uh-huh everyone wants to be better than
the competition so we are going to get
the best product absolutely and you know
what i was talking with palmer luckey
last year about you know PlayStation VR
and the competition right his
perspective was he wants them all to
succeed he wants them all to do well
because he doesn't want someone to try
it one of those VR things have a bad
experience and then right off VR forever
ever because then you've lost that
consumer and the mark
suffers BR you know for all our
enthusiasm for it have people played it
it still is going to be a tough shell
now a bit I was a VR naysayer like I
mentioned a couple segments ago i'm a pc
gamer at heart i play everything with a
mouse and a keyboard and I was like why
would I ever want this I'm always going
to want that mouse and keyboard in my
hands sure and then I like I played
hockey Olson a little bit it was alright
I I was doing keep talking nobody
explodes that's a pretty focused was the
early oculus yeah we really actually and
then I tried the vibe and I was like I
need a vibe I want to do this all the
time it's so fun this is the best how
what room in my house can I clear of all
other objects to have the vibe we've had
jeff cannata on hosting earlier and what
he's done is using some ikea products he
basically created like a fishing pole
esque mount from his like pc desk the
cables run on this poll that has some
give and then they come around to the
back of his helmet so oh not getting
tangled up he's just kind of he looks
like a fish dangling on a hook but it
seems neat and it seems like that's the
kind of you know solutions that people
are finding as we think about like ah
alright these things are really coming
they're here and they're also a little
more something we had a chance to
experiment with in and to kind of brag a
little bit i don't think anyone else has
done this yet but we did like space
pirate trainer ok what's a vibe game and
we set the vibe in a large studio space
and scream yeah there's a mod where you
can set up an extra vibe controller as a
time in every aim so you put that
controller on an actual camera and so
you can move the in-game camera and then
we're using a green screen so we can
track out all the green put the person
near then literally into the gate Rick
it's just to get the virtual camera to
line up where your actual camera is and
make it one to one as far as the
movement and I've been to also have a
complete green screen room and as many
pan up you can see kind of obviously our
space it is YouTube and digital media
and to see what VR is going to do for
let's place what it's going to do for
just YouTube gaming videos i think is
going to be very interested in the near
future do you think i mean if you know
obviously watching and someone in that
setup is really interesting and that's
like the ideal way to showcase vr which
is
really hard challenge but that takes a
lot of resources to get that set up
right yeah and one of the great things
about streaming is you know like it's
pretty low barrier to entry all things
considered do you think how do you see V
are shaping up as something that people
a well let try to watch or try to stream
in our case all it took was one really
smart guy yeah yeah not the tim baker
dad well in a studio space and a big
green yeah that does know we had a lot
of resources to be able to happen to do
this but even still I think it's gonna
bring us back to why people loved
watching Let's Plays of horror games
because net just throw on the PS VR and
let's see a let's play of someone
playing I want to see everyone playing
resident evil I want to see PewDiePie
doing and I want to see us doing it uh
markiplier and just it so easy just to
the picture-in-picture and you're going
to see a whole new level of scared
because you're in the game but I think
let's plays are gonna really benefit
from being your point I think streamers
beat us to the punch a little [ __ ] is
using green screen to put themselves
into the shower great way to utilize the
the space so I also would like to see
people doing you know the jumping around
that yeah physical element of this sort
of streaming you know streaming is to
some extent of performance and you know
seeing a fit a more physical element of
that yeah that's right really got it
seem like you really athletic streamer
how they're the ones that take over let
out of shape guys my gosh fall by the
wayside but we get out doing like sweet
jumps and new breed of gay gamers two
point oh yeah you go wireless you'll
have people do in real life 360 noscope
back flip shot tricks I'll be out of a
job yeah well we'll be waiting on the
side yeah I'm the doritos in the mound
yeah we better start taking gymnastics
clubs are you getting on the back with a
new wave that I would subscribe to that
yeah this uh nastics casa spaghetti
hardcore get a bad idea this III i think
is taking vr into a fantastic steps and
i think next year will be even more oily
i mean they're all be at market psv are
coming later this year pretty exciting
times for us here in the games industry
especially with VR hope you folks have
enjoyed our VR coverage here from
gamespot we've got one more alive
segment to close out the show
and that's looking far far into the
future for e3 2017 we'll be right back